we got Ralph Macchio here who of course
is he here yeah he's here he's right
outside okay good
he's starring in Cobra Kai season 2
which is now available on YouTube
premium man this series I don't know if
you've gotten a chance to check out any
of it Jim but when season 1 crept into
YouTube's premium it was almost this
thing where you were like what's YouTube
doing trying to create a premium service
why would they do a series about the
Karate Kid stuff but it like it caught
fire this series to the point where
obviously it's got a season two and you
know it's not this novelty thing people
are talking about Cobra Kai like it's
one of the best series on TV as then
without TV
I don't you gonna say best around
nothing's gonna ever take it down that's
the thing were you scared about going
like you cause you think this does not
give you on television if you're gonna
watch it scary right say this again we
scared just go straight to YouTube yeah
well listen I think the low expectations
initially with season 1 you know YouTube
is gonna be a silly 80s cash grab that
sounds like a bad idea it's gonna be I
think all that helped us when we came
out and and these writers and creators
have just such a great unique vision to
the show and that just took off so now
we seem really intelligent I mean it's
also helpful that you got everybody back
yeah yes right that this story is
actually told here's why it's so great
and this is why like I was able to lock
onto it so quickly because you watch
these movies especially in the 80s right
and you have these movies where there's
this big heroic ending and all you want
to believe is that daniel-san went on to
have this fabulous life where it was
just more success after more success and
more success and sweep the leg Johnny
went on to have his whole life over here
and you start this show in season 1 and
you look at both characters and even
though one's got money and one doesn't
the reality is that for both of those
characters life never got any better
right then that one moment the one
moment at the end of Karate Kid it was
the culminating moment for both of those
two when they're kids and they're just
living off of that glory ever since
right it's great it's fun because it's
you know life is more complicated than
the
black-and-white of what the original
Karate Kid film was good over evil and
the difference with with with Cobra Kai
is that it dives into the gray areas
there's moral ambiguity between these
characters episode 2 episode your
allegiance can change and write it by
allowing the characters to breathe in a
format say a five hour movie cut up into
ten half-hour parts which essentially is
what each season is allows for that and
and but they you know in season two
certainly they both have such good
intentions totally that but then it
winds up so is he a more likable guy
than you I haven't seen is he a more
likeable guy than he was in the Johnny
yeah yeah well listen he's trying to
he's trying to right the wrongs and and
shake his demons and and really with
good intentions but he can't get out
from under who he is
so you root for that right on the flip
side you have Larusso who has had the
greatest mentor a human Yoda in his life
and mr. Miyagi right he said he said all
the success is fine he's found a
beautiful woman great great family posit
you know financial security but yet this
Johnny Lawrence and his Cobra Kai is
such a wound on his his past they can't
allow it to become popular so it becomes
something that actually derails him from
his own focus and balance and life with
and therein lies the journey for these
two middle-aged guys trying to navigate
that that that part of life I think one
of the reasons why I liked it so much
was because like YouTube is what made me
look at Karate Kid completely
differently when those theories the
boundaries came out right now wait a
minute
what if Daniel was the [ __ ] the whole
time what if he's the villain money's no
video with a show yeah you come to this
nice town and watching this video and
I'm going yeah Johnny was right right
and then at least since it more so in
season one I think than season two but
in season one you really get that
perspective because Italy as season 1
starts it really is told from right
Johnny the first four at 5mb yeah
Daniel visits Miyagi's grave in episode
5 of season one and sort of recalibrates
his his life and begins to take fill
that void that's been missing for eight
years for that point he's set up as you
know by design as the successful guy
that's haunting Johnny Lawrence still
right you know and so by design the show
set up that way but yeah it feeds into
that the concept and when you there was
there was no one in 1984 or since
watching The Karate Kid film that ever
didn't root for Larusso to win at the
end of the game it's just over time the
internet pop culture has like you know
yeah I mean was he really came into this
town and stole his girlfriend he was
just gonna fix himself in his nerdy
greasy Italian from Jersey doing this
and then when he was rolling an innocent
joint in the bathroom he sprayed him
with water
screw him he is the bully yeah but I
don't think it holds water I don't know
I thought I thought yeah hey against you
I had a real thing for the girl in part
two to the I wish used to Korean girl
she's uh she's Okinawan Tamlin Tomita is
the actresses nameplate kumigar she's
fantastic I would love to find a like
we're always looking for in the long
haul of Cobra Kai hopefully we get to do
this for several or many seasons other
characters we'd like to to bring back
and we brought back Johnny's trainer for
season two let's meet a full-fledged oh
he's a character
now the the Darth Vader of the 80s right
the madman who started Cobra Kai yeah he
throws a wrench into everyone's plans
but she's a terrific actress I think
she's on the the good doctor now oh
she's still working yeah I do that
sometimes I'll go back to like an 80s
movie and you kind of wanted what
happened to this / - the others are yeah
there's they've been working all along
right they just don't look like they're
17 anymore Yeah right exactly they're
doing a TV series and I don't watch
there's also this great thing about
watching like I thought it was even more
so in this season season two than last
season but there's a little bit in last
season to where you've got these 80s
movie villains right that are having to
deal with millennial culture right so
you've got these guys there
like these super alpha-male eighties
movie villains
that are sitting there looking at
millennial high school kids trying to
make sense out of any of it yeah and
it's kind of perfect because it's not
like the point of view isn't necessarily
like oh look at these millennial kids
they don't understand it's more look at
how out of touch these movies are one
thing that the Johnny Lawrence character
is he's still stuck in the 80s and he
can't get out of that right there's a
fun scene in episode 3 of season 2 where
he quote-unquote discovers the internet
like that he doesn't have to pay for
porn anymore and it's kind of fun to us
his guy in his fifties trying to figure
out what a hash brown or hash tag is he
doesn't you know and he uses his
students alpha man and on the flip side
Larusso thinks he has it all figured out
and then learns in this season with
trying to spread the gospel of mr.
Miyagi and the great legacy and the
teachings that that helped his life out
he realizes pretty soon too just because
he has knowledge of a subject it's not
so it doesn't mean you know how to teach
it and so he is up against I mean
consider Larusso trying to build build
Miyagi do karate and convince
Millennials that they need to paint
fences wax cars and sailor decks you
know it's like the child labor laws are
coming into play and even have entered
he's got a he's got an uphill battle and
it's fun it's fun to touch on that stuff
it pays homage to what made the Karate
Kid a great story and and and within
great characters and yet make it
relevant for today in some way that's
what the show really does well it's
weird to pat morita like you know I'm
sure been acting for years and years and
the thing that he gets known for I mean
happy days kind of but and Arnold yeah
but this this thing you just never know
yeah like when it's gonna happen because
you know he becomes this iconic
characters so later later my Oscar
nomination of people don't know did he a
NASCAR nation mr. miyagi yep
Wow beat him to remember hung s noir
from The Killing Fields oh yeah the
feels don't have their own series yeah
I'm not rebooting that makes no sense
see it nam store that did you did you go
through any period in your life where
you were like I need to do anything
besides anything that could be compared
to this karate yeah gotta remove myself
there's a there was certainly a stretch
of time there was that I call it the
enough already which was probably 15
years ago late 90s or whatever with my
math but yeah I mean I sure there is
definitely I've never been okay I'm
gonna talk to Jim and Sam today but but
we're not gonna talk about that film
which is and people do that they do I
know they do they don't discuss our best
work I've always found that silly and
kind of ridiculous the the the the great
stuff now is that as I've gotten younger
and wiser I think that it's it's so rare
you have the opportunity to touch and
reach so many so many people with a
story wait and I get it because I'll get
six eight ten year old kids you know
that on the street they want to show me
the crane kick in it and want to dress
up in this character and you know it's
it's amazing you're able to do that
after 35 years in a positive way or have
parents watch a movie with their kids
that that part is awesome but on the on
the to add to that now I'm on like a
show called a deuce for HBO yeah it's a
really cool show Maggie Gyllenhaal James
Franco is a David Simon show and we're
in our third season and I get to play
this really crooked vice cop from that
era who would take money under the table
just just like the entire Police
Department did at that time in New York
City and it just it's awesome to be part
of the fabric of that show and yet have
this to do something different yeah I
want to ask you a non karate key
question about for you I really want to
know about your working on Broadway with
Burt young engineer and De Niro yeah
that was 1986 that was that was amazing
that was a play called coop and his
teddy bear we did at the Public Theater
downtown and it was the first time De
Niro had been on stage since you know he
was
I guess in imeem way way into only
Broadway that was his only Broadway and
and thing it was it was a big hot ticket
that summer and and we're at the
Longacre theater it was it was
spectacular and plus I grew up DeNiro
was you know De Niro of the 70s so this
was yeah the dream come true I came out
of the outsiders which was the first big
dream come true roll and then the Karate
Kid hit and then and then kuben his
teddy bear on broiler that was a big
summer for me 86 I had that Karate Kid 2
in the theaters and the Mets winning the
World Series so wow they offer you this
gig edition I audition I auditioned for
for Joseph Papp Joe Papp and and De Niro
and I was a nervous wreck which probably
played into the fact that the character
was struggling with his his father's a
very dominant drug dealer a Cuban drug
dealer in the Lower East Side of
Manhattan and the this kid that I played
was had an artistic writer mind and and
so he was torn between that so I think
the fact that I was a nervous wreck
added to the monologue that I had to do
who do they play who do their player who
didn't play my dad and Burt young played
my uncle uncle Jackie so and they were
you know they were drug dealers and and
he died there was no mom in the picture
so it was me and and then and the
characters that would come in and out of
the place is really a gritty probably
without DeNiro me and Burt young at that
time probably we never gotten uptown
mm-hmm
you know now you could do that but back
in you know you were either Broadway
musical or Arthur Miller or Death of a
Salesman those right shows that were on
Broadway so this was a 10-week limited
run but it was it was amazing that's
there's certain ones you want to go back
in time and just with my knowledge and
wisdom now go back and just redo that
and just take it all in anymore no
faster yeah everything was happening so
fast
I was right in the middle of the Karate
Kid Fame and this the part two was out
so that was the biggest of all that and
I was you know busy rooting for the Mets
when you do when you do when the karate
kids sequels end are you ready for them
to end are you going like no I was ready
for them that you
yeah I did three who did I talk about
the first one but you know there yeah I
was there because I felt it didn't take
too long for me to feel the heat that
that was a cage that was albeit when I'm
very proud of and even at the time but
it was tough to get outside those gates
when they remade it were you going like
what are you doing this for were you
looking at it as something separate or
first I said how can you remake
something and I'm not that old it says
you know now on Broadway like the things
are like the fourth revival of A Chorus
Line it's like I remember seeing the
original so there's that that wake up
moment that I'm not I was initially I
just you know initially I was taken
aback by how do you do that again which
is what everyone says yeah you know I
mean now they're doing West Side Story
who you would always say how do you do
that again
but so I was initially you know I felt
like okay I don't go to see movies when
I know how they're gonna end so I don't
really have interest I was looking for
more more original content that that
would take me on a journey that I'm not
used to but at the end of the day Will
Smith called me because I think I
mentioned that I was like didn't wasn't
in love with the concept of them
remaking the movie so I got the call I
know I'm missing with you baby I know he
said but we feel that there's more meat
on the bones here and if you want to be
involved in any way and which I didn't
but I respected it and Will Smith called
you and said I know I'm messing with
your baby but now you're messing with my
Overbrook which is his company is a one
of the executive producers of Cobra Kai
because in that that deal with Jerry
Weintraub Productions and Sony they they
have a piece of the franchise going
forward so I would assume they're quite
happy with the success of Cobra Kai I
would imagine so what did you say on the
phone Allah the doctor
I had an opening line I had an opening
line he first of all he was awesome and
gracious and all that stuff he's always
been into my views but I've been
presented himself that way but I did
have a line cuz I did meet him once
he auditioned for my cousin Vinnie and
when I was reading for my part and I
said that was the first and last time
that I ever got the part and you didn't
and that's what I got a laugh and we and
then he and he put Jaden on the phone I
felt very obi-wan to young Skywalker and
and they made you know listen that that
film the 2010 Karate Kid Vilma or the
kung fu kids that night yeah yeah it was
only enhanced legacy of the original
movie although it made people start
asking you about Karate Kid again I'm
sure thank you very much do you I mean
and I guess people because they're so
obsessed with everything else forget
that like that's another my cousin
Vinnie is another movie that is like
lived yeah for ever they never been a
period of time where that hasn't been a
movie that people are like how great is
that
did you do you have any idea when you're
doing something like that that it's this
is gonna be one of these things that
lasts forever
um I listen I I knew where I felt I mean
I thought you know Joe and Marissa it
was so clear that they just had a magic
you know together and then you know you
never know till they're done but you
look at that you look at Karate Kid The
Outsiders my cousin Vinnie there's three
of them that in that small period of
time for me it's pretty amazing that
they they stand the test of time and my
cousin Vinny's a late for dinner movie
if it's on you're late for dinner right
you just gotta wait for that one more
set up to pay itself off and that I'm
funnier than the next and from the
entire cast from you know Austin
Pendleton and as the stuttering public
defender and Fred Gwynne is the judge in
his last performance it's the last thing
yeah that was his last thing did you
hang out with Fred Gwynne at all Fred
Gwynne he had to German Shepherds as I
know that one was named Duchess and the
other was named Contessa how do I know
this because that's all I heard all that
Duchess Contessa Duchess can say he was
just calling these dogs constantly
gentlemen giant of a guy very private to
himself I didn't get to work with him
that much obviously Joe did
and it was didn't you have this not one
scene with him right I just well I'm in
the courtroom on it but but and him and
Joe were totally different and but they
look and different just in a different
way like Fred liked to do his coverage I
never seen this before and I found it so
interesting
he liked to his coverage and for those
of you listening know what that is it's
like different camera sizes like the
close-ups and all that stuff so when it
was just on him he didn't want the other
actors to do their dialogue he wanted
them to pantomime the dialogue so Joe
would have to like you know silently
like you know Charlie Chaplin or Buster
Keaton do his stuff and then and then
Fred would take his own cue for and do
his what a [ __ ] pro that's really
hard to do Mike is he got something
stepped on in 61
somebody must have stepped on a moment
that he wanted to deliver and that's the
way he did Wow and so not in this not in
this scenes when the cameras why of
course yeah but when it came in to get
those individual beats and a close-up he
didn't want he just wanted to take his
own beats so that was really that's one
of the things I remember him but a
gentleman to me and and a great perform
another great performance but it is Adly
is last is that is that now when you're
doing something like that that's such an
odd way to do it and you have a guy give
me Pesci had already done Raging Bull by
that point and I think you've done a
good fella's yeah he won the Oscar for
Goodfellas when we were shooting so he
was still like a merry legitimate guy
how does that conversation like when you
need another act and oscar-winning actor
to move his lips without saying anything
is that like a power players don't like
hey look would you mind I don't remember
how it happened I just remember Joe
saying me you see what I got to do we
and but he wasn't you know it wasn't I
wasn't disrespectful to Fred anyway but
he just and that's when I noticed it
because I was you know I wasn't in the
scene I was to the side on the table
when you're shooting a movie with a guy
like Joe Pesci and then he goes and wins
an Oscar and then he comes back to set
coming back with the Oscar yeah there's
the vibe change like hey guys I don't
know if you noticed yeah
yeah it was awesome then he starts
shouting when French doing is closed I
want to talk I'm gonna take this trophy
and put it right in front of the camera
so what's that was it to do to get you
to agree to do Cobra Kai because you
could have obviously been like the last
guy to come to the party I was the most
resistant smart to going back to the
well and was it based on the scripts and
the fact that wait a minute this is
actually a good show not just a
nostalgia there were no scripts oh my
god I mean they were scripts when we
shot the show but it was just a pitch
yeah it was a fully fleshed out pitch by
these three guys Jon Josh and Hayden
they had already gone to Sony they had
already gone to Jerry Weintraub
production Overbrook all they got all
the ducks in a row
they had zapka on board and they they
came to New York Tribeca and we sat
there for about three and a half hours
and it took a lot of listening and
understanding I got it and my gut was
that these guys had all good intentions
and that was the one thing that I
trusted that they they did not want to
you know do the eighties cash grab where
this is even though it was called Cobra
Kai and it initially starts out of the
through the eyes of Johnny Lawrence I
felt two things one this was the time if
I was gonna do it it was now and the
streaming services allow you to do these
like I say five hour movies and cut them
up into parts where 10 15 years ago
you'd have to make a two-hour major
motion pictures equal and that landscape
has changed because it's either Avengers
or Harry Potter or kind of nothing
that's it
and so they were and they were receptive
to the the things that were important to
me which is having the the spirit of the
miyagi character woven throughout the
series in that part of larusso's life as
he navigates his middle age and how that
would have to balance as a two-handed
lay at 50/50 once the show got up and
running and we pitched it all together I
jumped in and they're still nervous
about it you know up until it you know
became available I wasn't 100% sure but
you know I was ready to jump into the
pool I just had no idea how cold that
water would be and it was you know
lukewarm and perfect Tony Burton from
Buckwald is listening to this interview
very I bet he was the one who was behind
nor take cash crap
a big cash crab guy [ __ ] horrible in
pitch meetings I can't I'm terrible
listen there were five of us you had me
and Billy Zabka which used to just blow
they have two studio executives that
blew their minds just having us in the
room right because they think we're
gonna start fighting when it's like no
movies are not yeah and and and the
three writers who ran you know they had
everyone had their part so it was really
a presentation and they had season one
down and and and and ideas for season
two or three and beyond it was just it
was a well-orchestrated pitch it's tough
it's it's the only time I've ever been
in the room where the network's were
selling us on them and it was awesome
because we went to you know YouTube
Amazon Hulu Netflix all those and we had
multiple buyers the thing which never
happens or rarely the thing that the
reason why YouTube won this lottery if
you will is they had one card to play
they could not compete with Netflix and
Hulu in unless they said make ten
episodes we don't need to read it and
that's what they did
Wow because that was the way they got
yes yes the only way they would have
gotten the show I mean and so credit
credit Susanne Daniels and who's ahead
over there of their original content and
and and she didn't want to do that but
she knows she would not have had the
show and then and from the YouTube
perspective you know they had billions
of karate kid' hit they could look at
all those metrics and and data analytics
of how many people view videos from the
that are associated with karate kids so
you know and who gets more eyeballs than
YouTube well and like I said the synergy
of this idea that like the whole theory
of what we were talking about the
beginning of the interview of Daniel
being the bad guy but that all comes
from you to him so it's almost like
you're going right into this organic
thing right but I think I mean I think
it was worth it for YouTube because I
know a lot of people who didn't know
anything about anything
wouldn't even consider you to premium
until this series came on and it's a
real quality oh my god you have to see
this show and all of a sudden now
YouTube can flush out this hole yeah and
going forward I believe they're going to
I mean I shouldn't I don't know when
their official stuff is on this but
they're going to like the first episode
is available to everyone there will be a
time and they're working on this now
that they you can watch the show with
advertising commercials and see the show
and not necessarily be a Premium Member
the thing is with the show as soon as
you watch episode 1 you don't feel like
waiting another week to watch it with
commercials right is gonna be a once a
week that's that's there in discussion
right now for going forward so you show
like it's one of them all time yeah like
it's one of these shows where I you wait
this is this show all released at once
or is it released you could get you get
the you know first episode and it drives
you right to the you know the
subscription base it's one of those
things where I mean when it first came
on I was like let me just watch it to
see what it is like you know just for
the nostalgia for the fun like okay I
want to see what these guys are doing
and I mean over the course of two days
it was done like you stay up way later
than you thought you would right you get
through seven episodes the first night
it's had they're easily digestible at a
half hour yes you know so it strings
together night now it's awesome and I
appreciate it it's so we're we're loving
it these these things happen
occasionally and it's nice to have all
this stuff going on right now
one more Jim and Sam catch up with full
episodes and interviews from celebrity
guests anytime on demand using the
Sirius XM a/v